(groans in disgust)
- Are you gonna drink the whole glass?
- I’m not gonna drink the whole glass.
It smells like vomit.
("Stone Fox" by Warner/Chappell
Production Music)
(cheers and applause)
Thank you so much!
Welcome to BuzzFeed Taste Test Live.
I'm your host, Keith Habersberger.
Tonight's show is all about nachos.
(cheers and applause)
The thing about nachos is
even a shitty nacho is
still a pretty good nacho.
It's still a nacho.
It's sort of like sex in that regard.
(laughs)
I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time comparing sex to nachos,
I think you get that it's
all messy and we get that.
But I wanna prove my
theory that even a cheap,
average nacho, is still pretty okay.
So our first taste test
is of the cheapest, most average nacho,
which is, of course, from 7-Eleven.
Here to taste it live, right now,
are BuzzFeed's very own,
Maycie, Jen, and Jordan!
(cheers and applause)
- Ooh! They don't look bad!
- No. I can smell them already.
- What do they smell like?
- Do we just eat them, Keith?
- Yeah, you just eat them.
That's what you do with nachos.
(laughs)
It's a taste test show, Jen.
- I hate this cheese.
- I don't hate it.
- Fakest cheese I've ever had.
- It's a little plasticky,
the cheese is, but--
- It's a lot plasticky.
- It's not horrible.
- It's not bad. It's perfectly adequate.
- Jen is the only one who's into plastic.
(laughs)
She's fine with it.
- Even the chips don't taste good.
- When do you think you would actually
eat these in real life?
- When I was drunk, I would eat them.
(laughs)
- You know what, you guys
are absolutely right.
When you're drunk is
the perfect time to have
7-Eleven nachos and we
thought of that ahead of time,
so why don't we bring out
three shots of tequila!
(cheers and applause)
- Alright. Bottoms up, ladies.
Alright, don't get too carried away.
The thing is, we're actually
going to take you now to a room
with more tequila and
you are free to drink
as much of that as you like.
Obviously, stay responsible with it.
Then, we're gonna have you come
back at the end of the show
and eat those same nachos
and see if, maybe, you find
them more delicious, huh?
- Great, great.
(cheers and applause)
- How was the tequila room?
And I guess the cerveza room, as well?
- Yeah, I got over tequila, so.
- If you were this
drunk on a normal night,
what time in the evening would it be?
- Six?
(laughs)
- Jen!
- You start early!
- I'm gonna go with, like, 9:30?
- Oh, I was gonna say, like, 2 P.M.
Or, no! A.M.! A.M.! A.M.!
- It's okay. That's the tequila talking.
Well, let's take it on home.
Why don't you try, or retry,
those 7-Eleven nachos, now drunk.
- Wooh!
(cheers and applause)
- They're so beautiful.
- They are so beautiful.
- Are these the same nachos
or new 7-Eleven nachos?
- Girls, I don't know. I've
been here the whole time.
(laughs)
I think they're actually new.
We tried to provide you
with the same experience.
- I mean, that's very nice
of you guys, if that's right.
- Of course it is.
Jordan, you ate that so quickly!
(laughs)
You put the whole disk in your mouth.
- I liked them before,
but they're really good.
(laughs)
- How do they make you feel?
You're having a great time up there.
Jordan's just giggling.
- Actually, I really like the chips now.
- They're so cute.
(laughs)
- Jen! Are you, like,
turned on by these nachos?
What's going on over there?
- We don't have to talk
about it right now.
(laughs)
- Am I allowed to use the
guacamole on the table?
- That's disgusting.
- Please eat it. Eat it. Eat it.
- These would've been
better with guacamole,
but I'm not eating
guacamole off the table.
Jen! Oh my God! No!
- You could be happy, Maycie!
(laughs)
- Real quick question,
are these nachos better,
now that you're drunk?
- Yeah.
- They're great.
- Like, 100%.
- We did it, guys!
(cheers and applause)
You know, I kinda feel bad.
I got you guys all drunk,
right in front of all these people,
that's sort of embarrassing.
I thought to make it fair,
I would allow you guys
to embarrass me.
So, we actually have all the
ingredients to make nachos
and we're gonna bring them
out here with a blender.
Since I made you eat things drunk,
you're gonna make me
drink things I should eat.
There's probably a
logical misstep in there,
but we all wanna see me chug
some nachos stew, right?
(cheers and applause)
- Wait, you put tequila in it?
- Smoothies need liquid.
(laughs)
- Jordan!
- You put tequila?
It's gonna taste like vomit!
- Ooh!
(groans in disgust)
- Just a dash of milk.
- We need it. It has to blend!
- [Jordan] That's important in a recipe.
- Alright, is this good?
- No, stay focused on the job, ladies!
Stop eating! We gotta blend this stuff up!
Alright. Watch yourself.
- Oh my God, this is gross!
- I think. It looks like we made a
pretty good liquid out of those nachos.
I think we're ready to do this.
(cheers and applause)
- [Maysie] Keith! I feel bad.
- [Jen] Keith is so nice.
(groans in disgust)
- Are you gonna drink the whole glass?
- I'm not gonna drink the whole glass.
It smells like vomit.
- [Maysie] It looks like vomit.
- I mean, it's literally
chewed up nachos and booze.
It is vomit.
(laughs)
(indiscernible) much fun here
at BuzzFeed Taste Test Live.
- Keith, oh!
(laughs)
- We're having so much fun.
We tasted so many things.
- Oh my God. Keith!
(groans in disgust)
(laughs)
- We did it all, guys!
And you all were here
to help it all happen.
Thanks so much for coming out
to BuzzFeed Taste Test Live.
I think you can clearly say
this is nacho ordinary show!
We did it!
(cheers and applause)
- You wanna taste? Taste it?
Jen? Jen?
Yeah, get it. Get it, girl.
Yeah, girl! Yeah! Yeah!
- Oh my God! So bad!
- Just smelling it was enough.
- Oh, it's vile.